Chuck time for another explainer all
right now I love explainers you've been
loving the explainers I you know they
stick with me man they're very cool okay
so I got one here you ready go ahead I
how long is a
year all right I I didn't realize uh you
thought I was that stupid that you had
to explain that to me I I said I loved
explainers I didn't real that we were
getting down to the remedial levels know
yeah hello Chuck hi so yeah what let's
let's tell you what a year is yeah you
tell me so what do you what is a year
here's a year take this crayon and I
want you to draw I want you to draw me a
timeline
Chuck a year a year is a trip around the
Sun okay so how long does that take uh
we say that it takes
365 days but but I got a feeling that
you're going to tell me somehow that is
not the case that is totally not the
case that is not the case oh wow it is
not the case so a as a matter of social
civil
convenience okay uh the year is mapped
out to 365 days all right all right with
12 months each having you know as low as
28 as few as 28 days and up to 31 days
add all that up get 365 and then every
four years we stick another day in there
on that well watch that's what I'm
getting at so that 365 days and we
celebrate New Year's Day right Earth has
not yet completed its orbit around the
sun wait a minute so you're saying to me
that when we go January 1 yay all right
kiss when you go January 1st to January
1 right each time time we do it right
Earth is six
hours
behind the completion of one trip around
the Sun oh crap I did not know that well
I'm telling you you got think first of
all that is significant in terms of
amount of time yes it is okay so so
rather than celebrate the New Year in
these six hour increments through no we
just cleanly divide the into whole days
because we don't want to mess with a day
you wake up in the morning you go to
sleep the sun rises it sets it's day
it's night we want to keep that intact
so we ignore the six
hours okay all right so now how long
you're going to ignore the six hours
well I'm gonna say not very long okay so
if you if you ignore it for four years
then how many hours have you ignored 24
6times 4 bada big
so you then
throw a day back into the calendar that
makes sense every six hours 6 hours four
years that's a day throw the day back in
and you're back in line and we give that
day to the very needy February um of
course Black History Month there was the
short exactly of course they would do
that you know that just like yeah not
only are we missing the
day it's the shortest month of the year
and uh oh by the way black people here
you go by the way this shortest month
even when you give it an extra day even
when you give it an extra day we still
don't we still come up
short that's amazing all right so so so
now and now everything's sort of even St
okay right all right so what we've
talked I think we've talked about before
the fact that that
overcorrects did I did I ever mention
that to you okay now I I believe we did
but we were talking about it in a
different it might have been in a
different context calendar calendars
there was like a Julian calendar we
talked about this two years ago I'm
trying to think of let bring some of it
back because it's in it's relates to the
year yeah so I told you six hours but
it's not six hours okay of course I mean
that's right because that only makes
sense okay it's a trip around the Sun
365 days except it's not um and it's six
hours except it's not okay it's a little
less than six hours okay all right so
since it's a little less than six hours
if you add up four of those you don't
quite have a full day do you no yeah
exactly little yet we put in a full day
right so it turns out over a
century you've accumulated an extra day
that shouldn't be
there okay so every
century when it would have been a leap
day you take it out
so okay gotcha because we're right we've
accumulated that day we don't need to
have the leap year that time so we just
let it go the day self-corrects because
the accounting The Ledger is now
balanced except ex God it's not quite oh
God God what okay okay so it turns out
that overcorrects it by just a little
bit of course it would okay right
overcorrects it
so over 400
years there's a day that should be in
there that
isn't okay okay so every 400 years which
counts as a hundred-year increment okay
where you wouldn't taking out the leap
day right every 400 years you put the
leap day back in you put it back in
because you wouldn't have taken it out
because it's the correction for the
times that over that already was
accumulated correct you would have you
wouldn't have you would have just let
things be but now over 400 years because
it wasn't quite what it is right just a
little bit it took 400 years now it's
just like hey now you know what we're
going to do because we actually did
accumulate over all this time so now
we're going to of a day back in here and
finally every 4 and you know something
the year
2000 was just such a year so most people
who said well year 2000 is divisible by
four it's a leap
year had no clue how rare a leap year
that is right that was the leap year
that wasn't yeah correct there was no
Leap Day in the year 1900 or in the year
1700 or in the year 1600
so all those Century years had to
accumulate a 400-year interval we're up
to the year 2000 it's got a leap day and
people thought that was a normal leap
day but it wasn't but it wasn't wow yep
that's actually a a w look at that that
this okay it's all because we're not
correcting by the precise amount we're
correcting by whole days now and there's
nothing in the UN Earth's orbit around
the sun doesn't care about how long it
takes Earth to rotate on its AIS but we
do so we we are shoehorning in our days
with respect to how long it takes Earth
to go around the Sun but wait
oh
we okay so that year is the time it
takes the sun's and Earth's relationship
to repeat in such a way that the
seasons stay attached to the months of
the year we've given them
to okay so our year is based on the
seasonal calendar because we're
historically agrarian agrarian yeah
planting sewing reaping all that crap it
makes sense okay it turns out that the
seasonal
calendar is slightly different from the
time it takes Earth to return to the
same spot in its
orbit ah we simply don't use that
calendar and that's called a siderial
year where we match up with the Stars
that surround the Sun but our Seasons
don't match up with the stars and the
Stars migrate through the year spring
will always be in March but the sky you
see in the springtime in March right
will
shift against the calendar because
that's not the year that we're based on
right exactly okay so whatever year
you're based on that repeats every year
other accountings will then shift
relative to it and so when we return to
our spot in space relative to all the
stars that's a different length of time
than the time for us to repeat the
seasons right and so so so we have a
seasonal year that's the year we know
and love then it's called the siderial
year siderial me just simply means Star
right okay that's the year where you
look up and you have to find a point and
we got to return to that point to that
point and if we did that then the
seasons would Drift We The Stars would
stay where they are right right okay
right but we'd be getting a little you
know you know but we don't have to worry
about that anymore because we have
climate
change so we have solved that
problem solve the calendar problem we
solve the calendar problem ain't no
winter there no nothing
baby okay but wait one L there's another
kind of year okay okay Earth is an
ellipse in its or orbit right okay so
that means sometimes it's closer to the
Sun and sometimes it's farthest right
we're closest to the Sun in July
farthest in in January early January so
that
ellipse precesses around the Sun so in
other words if you look if you step back
and look at the ellipse orbit around the
Sun and watch it like for thousands of
years that entire
ellipse will turn around the Sun okay
it's called procession it's a there
various kinds of procession that's one
of them so if you
timed the time between our closest point
to the Sun and our closest point to the
sun again that's a kind of a year isn't
it yeah it would be yeah that would be a
year within our orbit that's a different
length Year from the siderial year a
different length Year from our from our
seasonal year wow I
now here's the thing yeah how how much
older am I uh based on all these
years it's a very small difference
between them okay yeah yeah it's not
right that no I'm just seeing if I can
cheat the
system yeah just consider that what we
chose as a year is in a sense arbitrary
not that the length of the year is
arbitrary but we had a choice of three
right and and we don't care about
whether the stars in March stay the
stars in March we care that March always
has spring that's at least in the
northern hemisphere right yeah exactly
so there you go that's that's a year in
a nutshell that was good stuff I'm gonna
say I you know when you started off what
with you know what is a year I was kind
of like you lost it bro you finally lost
it he's finally
gone but you pulled it out I gotta tell
you you pulled it out this was a good
one this was that's kind of the whole
point explainers that's true that's true
this has been another star talk
explainer as always keep looking
[Music]
up